bonjour nous sommes le jeudi 15 janvier
merci de nous rejoindre dans filcho
l'émission qui revient sur votre
actualité économique locale on commence
tout suite avec les titres de cette
édition c'est un projet qui stagne
depuis des années la zone d'activité des
portes de Sanir située près de
l'aréodrome pourrait enfin sortir de
terre le promoteur a obtenu l'aval de la
Direction générale de l'aviation civile
les finances de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin à l'équilibre
pour 2015 cette semaine le budget a été
voté si la situation s'est un peu
améliorée par rapport à 2014 les
économies de rigueur ne font pas
l'unanimité cette semaine nous mettons
la mode à l'honneur avec une jeune
créatrice de vêtements viinoise elle est
styliste et lance sa marque de costume
pour homme enfin dans notre entretien
cette semaine nous parlerons du club
face et de ses initiatives pour 2015
pour pour cela nous sommes avec Mohamed
monouri bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur du club face nous ferons donc
avec vous le bilan de l'année qui vient
de se déroulé et nous parlerons des
projets et ambitions pour 2015 mais
avant cela passons en revue l'actualité
économique de la
semaine je vous le disais en titre
depuis des années le projet est bloqué
mais peut-être plus pour longtemps la
zone d'activité des portes de saint-sy
située en bordure de l'aérodrome de la
ville pour pourrait enfin sortir de
terre elle a rencontré nombre de
difficultés mais en décembre dernier le
nouveau projet présenté par Camar
finance a obtenu l'aval de la Direction
générale de l'aviation civile
regardez la ville de Saint- CIR l'espère
ce projet sera le bon situé en bordure
de l'aérodrome le projet des portes de
saint-sy prévoit la réalisation
d'environ 45000 m² d'activité la
proposition de Camar finance a été
repensée depuis sa première présentation
il y a un an et demi le projet des
portes de saint-sir est un projet de
parc
d'activités qui permettra de développer
sur la commune de saint-ciier- l'école
une zone d'activité artisanale
technologique et de bureau saint-ciè
l'école est une ville en constant
développement elle est à proximité de
Versailles on sait que cette zone manque
de locaux de bureaux et de surfac
disponibles pour différents types de
d'entreprises et notamment des petites
entreprises des artisans qui
souhaiteraient s'implanter dans des
petites unités le montant des
investissements devrait avoisiner les 80
millions d'euros soutenu par la mairie
cette zone d'activité pourrait générer
des centaines d'emplois seul problème la
proximité avec l'aérodrome depuis
plusieurs années le gas groupement des
usagers de l'aérodrome de saint-sir
l'école s'oppose à tout projet sur le
site monsieur Jamin m'a proposé qu'on se
rencontre et on a dit qu'on était
d'accord chose nous nous nous cherchons
à protéger d'une part notre sécurité en
tant que pilote et d'autre part nous
cherchons à protéger notre aérodrô en
tant que infrastructure publique
et en tant
que parti essentiel du patrimoine
aéronautique français des discussions
devraient avoir lieu courant février le
promoteur espère déposer un permis de
construire en juin
2015 cette semaine le vote du budget de
l'université versaill tin s'est déroulé
à Versailles il a été voté en décembre
dernier les étudiants s'étaient invités
au conseil d'administration obligeant
les représentant à reporter le vote en
2014 je le rappelle le budget de la
faculté était déficitaire cette année
encore des économies seront réalisé pour
revenir à l'équilibre regardez ce
reportage réalisé avec William
l des grilles fermées une chaîne et un
filtrage à l'entrée seuls les membres du
conseil d'administration sont autorisés
à entrer au siège de l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin des mesures
prises pour éviter les débordements du
mois de décembre où des étudiants
s'étaient invités au conseil
d'administration pour témoigner de leur
craintes des craintes à propos du budget
2015 toujours d'actualité le
gouvernement a mis la priorité jeunesse
complètement de côté du coup il fallait
taper du point sur la table cette fois
ce que je vais leur dire c'est en gros
soyez avec nous ne n'acceptez pas
l'austérité dans les budgets soyez avec
nous revendiquez vous aussi le fait que
l'État redonne de l'argent plus d'argent
chaque année pour pouvoir palier aux aux
dépenses obligatoires et qu'on arrête de
couper dans les formations que les
étudiants arrêtent de payer les les
pocass quoi l'UNEF n'a pas prévu
aujourd'hui d'envahir la Réunion le vote
est symbolique le budget de l'université
est sous tutelle du rectorat un plan
d'économie a été mis en place des
filières ont été fermées comme la
licence taps à versaill des économies
lourdes de conséquences selon le
syndicat CGT nous avons des personnels
qui sont partis de leur plein gré vu
l'état de l'université et le le budget
qui est
effectivement
insuffisant nous nos revendications sont
de bien sûr demander au ministère plus
d'argent pour que nous puissions
fonctionner simplement
correctement faut savoir qu'actuellement
l'année dernière nous avons fonctionné
avec 25 % de budget pour les labos et
actuellement nous avons il a été voté et
décidé par la direction un budget à 50 %
pour les les labos du côté des
enseignants on ne comprend pas bien ces
réductions jugé facultatives avec ce
budget ils s'attendent à une situation
légèrement meilleur qu'en 2014 mais sans
grande satisfaction 2015 va être une
année difficile encore pour les
personnels et pour faire fonctionner et
tourner nos formations c'est
incontestable tout ce qu'on peut espérer
c'est que le ministère en prenne à un
moment ou un autre vraiment conscience
qu'à lu VSQ comme ailleurs nous sommes
dans une sousdotation qui est chronique
maintenant et qui n'est plus qui n'est
pas tenable sur le long terme si nous
avons des budgets compressés des budgets
réduits ce n'est pas parce qu'il faut
faire plus d'économie dans l'absolu
c'est parce que le gouvernement fait le
choix de donner 6 milliards et demi en
crédit impô recherche sur des
dispositifs dont tout le monde sa ENF en
tout cas beaucoup le disent qui sont
plutôt relativement inefficace donc
c'est ça la vraie la vraie clé je dirais
après ça lève rien au fait que dans
chaque établissement il y a des choix à
faire des choix politiques de gestion et
rien il y a aucun problème avec ça
résultat du vote 17 pour 8 contre une
abstention le budget est acté on est
dans la dynamique voir une dynamique
plutôt positive puisqu'on peut mettre
plus de crédit de fonctionnement qu'on
avait pu en mettre en 2014 donc c'est
peut-être pas encore le bonheur le
paradis mais on a pu multiplier par deux
les budgets de fonctionnement des UFR
laboratoire et aussi un autre signe
intéressant c'est qu'on offre des
emplois recrutement alors queannée
dernière il y avait pas eu en l'année
dernière oui en 2014 avait pas eu de
recrutement donc voilà on recrute donc
des igns chercheurs également des
personnels administratifs ingénieurs
technique cette année serait-elle plus
sereine c'est ce que pense l'université
en 2014 elle a réussi à ramener le
budget à
l'équilibre la ville de véisine ne fait
plus partie d'aucune agglomération après
de nombreuses péripéties juridiques les
préfets des hautes scènes ont ont signé
le 30 décembre dernier un arrêt
autorisant la commune de véis ville
coublé à quitter la communauté
d'agglomération Grand-Paris saine-ouest
pour l'année 2015 la ville aura ainsi le
statut de commune isolée elle pourra
donc rejoindre la communauté
d'agglomération versailles- grand parc
le 1er janvier 2016 cette décision est
liée aux contraintes du budget de la
commune c'est une solution qui arrange
tout le monde selon le maire UMP de véis
ville àoublé Pascal
tevenau la première et la deuxème place
ce sont les places qu'occupent
respectivement les centres de recherche
de Renaud guillancour et celui de PSA
avaentlisi dans le classement des 100
premiers centres de recherche de
développement de France ce classement a
été publié par la revue industrie et
technologie la semaine dernière d'autres
entreprises yvelinoises sont également
présentes dans ce classement on notera
donc Zodiac Aerospace à plaisir à la 14e
place d'assau système à véisi vill
coublé qui occupe la 17e position et un
peu plus loin dans le classement à car
Resarch à Guy en cours qui est 69e alors
la recherche et développement tient une
place centrale dans la filière aut
mobile yvelinoise puisque 15000 emplois
environ lui sont consacrés pour rappel
plus de 150 entreprises du secteur sont
aujourd'hui implanté sur le territoire
je vous propose maintenant de passer à
notre entretien de la
semaine cette semaine je le rappelle
nous sommes avec Mohamed monsouri donc
le directeur du club face alors tout
d'abord Mohamed monsouri est-ce que vous
pouvez me rappeler un petit peu l'action
du club F ses objectifs ce qu'il fait
son essence même oui bonsoir donc le
club face a été créé en 1999 donc à
l'initiative de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de 50 ans en Yveline et
puis du réseau national Fas fondation
agir contre l'exclusion et en fait le le
le l'objectif principal de réseau Fas
c'est de pouvoir fédérer d'accompagner
le monde économique dans une démarche
sociétale donc on a différents champs
d'action on a effectivement un champ
d'action autour de la de l'école
favoriser des liens entre les écoles et
puis les entreprises on a un champ
d'action autour de l'emploi notamment au
travers de euh d'action de parrainage on
a également un champ d'action autour de
l'égalité donc qui prend la forme
d'atelier interentreprise sur des sujets
en li avec les questions de diversité et
puis un autre champ qui est le champ
territoire où là c'est toute la
contribution du club sur l'animation et
la vie du du territoire de cquanttin
nielin d'accord alors pour cette année
l'année qui vient de se passer donc 2014
quel bilan faites-vous un petit peu bah
bilan plutôt positif puisque
effectivement on a eu en 2014 plusieurs
actions qui ont été menées avec des
résultats probants euh on a par exemple
sur l'axe école touché 330 élèves toute
action école confondu au travers des
visites d'entreprise au travers de notre
participation à la semaine de de
l'industrie au travers de également
notre participation à la semaine école
entreprise et puis des actions qui ont
été menées permettant aussi aux jeunes
de pouvoir favoriser la en tout cas de
découvrir le monde de l'entreprise et
puis de découvrir également les métiers
présents sur le sur le territoire je
pense également à la graine d'entreprise
qui a été menée au cours de cette année
2014 et puis qui continue sur l'année
2015 sur l'axe emploi là aussi des
résultats assez probants puisqu'on est
sur une centaine de personnes
accompagnées avec un taux de retour à
l'emplo de à peu près 60 65 personnes
donc qui dans le contexte actuel est
plutôt un résultat très très
satisfaisant en tout cas nous on le
considère tel qu'el et puis avec en
point d'or forcément le l'anniversaire
des 15 ans du du club qui sont déroulés
le 16 octobre dernier au Théâtre de 50
ans Niven alors justement enfin vous
parliez un petit peu des des jeunes
quels ateliers ont bien marché je
suppose que les visites d'entreprise
voilà c'est quelque chose qui qui motive
peut-être les jeunes pour voilà aller
vers l'emploi et leur expliquer un petit
peu comment ça se passe vous pouvezm
dire un peu plus oui et puis c'est
effectivement ce sont des actions très
concrètes he très pragmatiques nous
c'est notre positionnement c'est
effectivement être sur dans l'action sur
le terrain auprès des partenaires auprès
des acteurs auprès des entreprises donc
ça passe par effectivement ce type
d'action des visites d'entreprise donc
là ce sont les jeunes qui vont aller
découvrir une entreprise comment
fonctionne une entreprise dans
l'intérieur on a effectivement d'autres
actions type graine d'entreprise où là
on va accompagner pendant toute une
année une classe d'élèves dans le cadre
d'un projet pédagogique de création
d'entreprise et puis sur l'acent poid
des ateliers aussi collectifs qui ont
beaucoup de succès également en 2014
puisqu'on a à peu près une centaines de
participants sur ces différents ateliers
et puis les ateliers également club 45+
qu'on organise à la cté des métiers donc
une palette d'action qui permet à nos
entreprises partenaires de pouvoir
s'impliquer localement sur les questions
d'emploi et puis sur les questions de
lien entre les écoles et puis les
entreprises et justement les seigneurs
est-ce que vous vous en occupez de plus
en plus il y a de plus en plus de de
plus de 45 ans on va dire qui viennent
vers vous pour l'emploi pour la
recherche d'un emploi ou peut-être la la
la reconversion alors ce qu'on constate
effectivement depuis ces dernières
années c'est que parmi les personnes
accompagnées nous avons de plus en plus
de de seniors ce qui était pas le cas il
y a quelques années c'est-à-dire que on
avait effectivement des profils types
qu'on accompagnait et aujourd'hui on a
de plus en plus de de profils 10 senior
et c'est pourquoi on a aussi souhaiter
proposer des actions personnalisées
auprès du public senior parce que
lorsqu'on accompagne un public senior
forcément c'est pas la même façon qu'un
qu'un public jeune donc on a dû
également s'adapter on a dû faire
évoluer aussi notre manière
d'accompagner ce public là donc ça passe
par des ateliers club 45+ à la cété des
métiers et puis un accompagnement
individualisé auprès de ce type de
public c'est plus compliqué
d'accompagner les les seniors que les
jeunes est-ce que il y a des demandes
particulières il faut je sais pas
peut-être avoir un un pas un management
mais un accompagnement qui est plus plus
sensible ou je sais pas oui oui si vous
voulez le le seigneor il arrive avec son
expérience professionnelle il arrive
avec un un vécu il arrive effectivement
avec un un un un bagage donc tout ça il
faut le prendre en compte ce qui est pas
le cas de d'un jeune qui démarre dans
dans la vie active donc il faut déjà
faire un travail de de deuil par rapport
à l'expérience passée donc on disant
effectivement qu'au senior il a eu une
certaine expérience professionnelle sur
laquelle il va pouvoir construire aussi
une offre de service une offre de
compéten donc on va l'amener aussi à
faire évoluer sa posture passer d'une
posture de demandeur d'emploi à une
posture d'offreur de service d'accord et
justement alors voilà qu'on parle de
demande d'emploi chômage pour 2015 on
s'annonce enfin pas qui va qui va il ne
va pas baisser justement vous avez des
projets pour 2015 des initiatives
particulières qui vont arriver oui bah
vous nous connaissez he le club face est
toujours dans l'innovation en tout cas
on tente toujours d'avoir une démarche
innovante et puis de mettre en place de
de nouvelles actions de nouvelles
initiatives sur l'école on a classe en
entreprise qui va être menée avec une
entreprise partenaire et puis un
établissement scolaire du territoire qui
je le rappelle permet à un groupe
d'élèves d'être immergé dans les locaux
d'une entreprise partenaire et donc il y
a un programme pédagogique qui va être
défini et les cours vont être assurés et
préparés entre des binômes enseignants
professionnels sur la partie emploi donc
c'est la mise en place de Job Academy
donc qui permet une entreprise
partenaire de pouvoir mettre à
disposition des parins et des marines
des collaborateurs de l'entreprise et
tout ça porté par l'entreprise avec
également des ateliers collectifs donc
vraiment pour porter cette dynamique
d'accompagnement permettant aux
chercheurs d'emploi de pouvoir avancer
dans leur démarche et puis on a
effectivement d'autres sujets qui sont
la participation également du club à des
projets de territoire on a par exemple
en projet le forum de l'apprentissage on
a également la participation à la
semaine de de l'industrie donc qui aura
lieu au mois de au mois d'avril vous
vous le voyez donc l'actualité au niveau
du du club est est très riche qui
s'annonce pour cette année 2015 on parla
en 2015 de la taxe d'apprentissage don
vous allez peut-être pouvoir bénéficier
en tant que que réseau que club c'est
cela PZ m' dire plus oui autre sujet
effectivement fait fait nouveau pour
cette année 2015 c'est que le club face
va être habilité à percevoir une partie
de la taxe d'apprentissage donc
l'entreprise qui a effectivement des
apprentis est amenée à verser une partie
de cette taxe d'apprentissage et donc le
club est habilité pour percevoir donc
une partie de cette taxe d'
apprentissage à hauteur de 65 % ce qu'on
appelle du hors quota donc je vais pas
rentrer forcément dans les détails
techniques mais l'entreprise c'est aussi
également une manière pour elle de
contribuer sa participation et sa
collaboration sur le territoire avec des
le soutien d'actions très concrètes
porter vers le lien entre l'école et
puis l'entreprise est-ce que voilà vous
avez plus besoin en de de donc cette
taxe d'apprentissage que les entreprises
peuvent vous reverser ou peut-être plus
de parins quels sont vraiment voilà les
ce qui devient un peu nécessaire en ce
moment pour vous vos besoins actuels bah
nous si on fait un appel global aux
entreprises c'est-à-dire que nous on
accueille les entreprises les bras
ouverts euh on a effectivement une
démarche permanente d'aller à la
rencontre des entreprises des TPE des
PME des grands groupes pour permettre
également à l'entreprise de s'inscrire
dans le cadre de une démarche
territoriale et puis d'inscrir
l'entreprise dans l'écosystème 50 ans
nieline en étant partenaire du du club
donc c'est effectivement dire aux
entreprises qu'on a besoin de VOUS qu'on
a besoin des entreprises mais que les
entreprises ont également besoin d'un
partenaire comme le club c'est un c'est
du gagnant gagnant euh et là
effectivement donc on je fait un appel
pour recruter de nouveaux parins Maren
sur l'emploi puisque plus on aura un
réseau de parins Maren et plus on aura
d'entreprises qui vont venir rejoindre
le club plus effectivement ce sera des
solutions permettant à nos publics
d'avancer dans leur recherche d'emploi
mais également pour les jeunes de
découvrir de nouveaux métiers et puis
effectivement c'est une autre
contribution une autre manière de
contribuer c'est de verser une partie de
cette taxe d'apprentissage donc tous les
documents sont mis en ligne sur le site
Internet de face Saint-Quentin et bien
vous avez entendu l'appel voilà si vous
souhaitez être vre parrain et travailler
avec le club face n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur site internet pour avoir plus
d'informations merci beaucoup Mohamed
monsouri d'être venu sur notre plateau
merci à vous je vous propose maintenant
de passer au chiffres de la
semaine 48,9 % c'est le pourcentage des
Français qui ont participé au sold
d'hiver lors du premier weekend de
lancement selon un sondage Toluna
réalisé le samedi 10 et dimanche 11
janvier la baisse est notable par
rapport à la même période l'an dernier
environ trois points de moins les soldes
convencent mal c'est un phénomène qui
est en partie lié notamment aux
attentats terroristes de la semaine
dernière qui a touché bon nombre de
Français sur les 5 premiers jours des
soldes la fréquentation a reculé de 12 %
en Île-de-France selon les chiffres du
Conseil national des centres commerciaux
commerciaux pardon pour tenter de
limiter la casse les commerçants ont
débuté la deuxème desmarque plutôt que
prévu et nous restons dans la mode je
propose maintenant de passer au métier
de la
semaine
et oui je vous le disais nous restons
dans la mode et les vêtements avec ce
métier une profession qui fait rêver
styliste créateur certains travaillent
dans de grandes maisons de hautes
couture d'autres dans des ateliers ou
des entreprises un peu plus modestes
c'est le cas de Marie audile royé elle
est installée à voisin le Bretonneux et
elle confectionne notamment des costumes
pour homme elle a accepté de nous parler
de son métier regardez ce portrait
réalisé avec elodiman et Romain
rpin
tout commence sur du papier c'est là que
prennent forme les idées de Marie Odille
des inspirations qu'elle confectionne
par la suite à 28 ans cette styliste
créatrice vie chinoise vient de lancer
sa marque de costume pour hommes les
vêtements masculins sont ceux qu'elle
affectionne le plus j'aime bien la coupe
j'aime bien la technique d'un côté c'est
plus simple que faire des vêtements pour
FEM qu'un costume pouvez faire de la
nouveauté ça aussi le challenge la
nouveauté avec avec quelque chose qui
reste tout le temps stable travailler
dans le milieu de la mode un rêve
d'enfant pour Marie od deal après un
beep puis un bac pro métier de la mode
elle fait un BTS option gestion de
production toujours dans cette même
filière à la suite d'un voyage d'un an
en Irlande la styliste rentre chez elle
et crée l'atelier de la lande je me suis
dit ben de chercher un travail qu'on
risque pas peut-être pas me donner selon
mon expérience sel mon truc pourquoi pas
créer ma propre entreprise sachant que
j'engage que moi j'engage personne
d'autre j'ai l'argent devant moi je me
suis lancée pendant 5 ans elle donne des
cours de cout dans son atelier et
réfléchit à son projet avant de se
lancer l'expérience est importante
savoir coudre et utiliser les
différentes techniques est essentiel un
styliste doit maîtriser toutes les
étapes de la confection d'un vêtement je
su très technique j'adore donne un
problème à résoudre ça que j'aime bien
dans la couture c'est qu'il a toujours
un problème à résoudre et trouver la
solution au problème il faut avoir
énormément d'imagination parce que le
clent il arrive il vous pose une
question et il faut savoir répondre en
moin de 5 minutes poures costumes c'est
le client qui décide de Ch détail de la
couleur la coupe du pantalon jusqu'aux
poches de la veste les prix
s'échelonnent entre 400 et 1500 € selon
les modèles Mario od prend les
mensurations et envoie les détails à un
fabricant elle s'occupe ensuite des
retouches ce n'est pas du surmesure mais
de la grande mesure on arrange selon la
taille et tout on arrange tout le truc
par exemple on veut éviter que ça baille
ici parce que souvent ça baille au
niveau du au niveau du costume on
arrange tous ces petits détails pour que
ça devienne vraiment quelque chose de
nickel et vraiment auprès du corps c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on peut avoir en
magasin on va on va acheter un costume
en magasin c'est un costume qu'on peut
retrouver après sur quelqu'un d'autre
celui-là je le retrouverai pas sur
quelqu'un d'autre et c'est ça le enfin
le le c'est un concept que je trouve
très sympa il faut ensuite choisir les
tissus et les motifs Benoît a le droit à
une attention toute particulière il fait
partie des mannequins non professionnels
choisi pour représenter la collection de
Marie ODIL en échange de leur travail
elle leur a tous confectionné le costume
de leur choix pour se lancer elle a dû
débourser 20000 € la création d'une
marque demande beaucoup d'argent alors
il faut être imaginatif et ingénieux
j'ai envie que les gens se disent
j'étais là j contribué ça m'appartient
un peu je travaillé mes amis je
travaillé les gens qui m'entourent parce
que je vois pas pourquoi je vais prendre
une grosse boîte pour obtenir ce que je
veux voilà pour avir pas obtenir ce que
je veux mais pour pour Esser à
travailler une entreprise familiale et
amicale Marie ODIL l'a faite à son image
du surmesure pour la
créatrice et si ce sujet vous a plu
sachez que l'atelier de la landandre
ouvre ses portes dès demain jusqu'à
dimanche au curieux passons maintenant à
l'entreprise de la semaine
pardon l'entreprise de la semaine est
une petite savonnerie artisanale
inontaine Stéphanie griillard Sigel
s'est lancée dans cette aventure il y a
3 ans elle nous a reçu dans sa petite
entreprise regardez ce reportage réalisé
avec patri Jacques de dixmud et Romain
ruspin chaque semaine c'est avec sa
propre voiture qu'elle fait ses
livraisons aujourd'hui Stéphanie va
réapprovisionner un salon de coiffure
qui vend ses
savons bonjour tout le monde
bonjour ici elle fait comme chez elle la
chef d'entreprise connaît très bien les
distributeurs de ses produits j'essaie
de rester au maximum dans le local dans
la distribution j'en ai trois quatre
petits magasins bio avec qui je
travaille était ma première pensée en
fait cétait après il y a les petits
marchés Noël les petits marchés de
créateurs qui a un petit peu de temps en
temps par-ci par là ses savons pour le
corps et le visage Stéphanie les produit
depuis 3 ans chez elle dans sa maison à
Montini le Bretonneux c'est ici que se
cache son laboratoire un laboratoire un
peu particulier il n'y a ni produit
chimiques ni cuve de cuisson c'est la
méthode de saponification à froid il y a
pas de chauffe pendant la fabrication et
c'est pour conférer au savon plus de de
pouvoir hydratant plus de et préserver
la qualité des des huiles qui sont elle
première pression à froid les huiles
essentielles qu'on doit pas chauffer
parce que ça les altère les savons de la
jeune entrepreneur sont naturell et
biologique toutes les matières premières
utilisées comme les huiles les essences
de fleurs ou le beurre de karité sont
certifiés biologiques elle doit aussi
respecter les mêmes normes qu'une
savonnerie industrielle des normes
contraignantes sur la lumière la
température et les locaux en général ici
c'était un cararage et on a du coup on a
tout transformé pour que ce soit une
savonnerie et qui soit bien dans les
clous une heure est nécessaire pour
fabriquer 40 kg de savon ce qui prend le
plus de temps c'est la saponification à
froid ce processus chimique qui permet
au liquide de se durcir et de
synthétiser le savon c'est le beurre de
karité et le beurre de de noix de coco
qu'on met avec donc l'huile
d'olive
voilà donc là on a nos quatre huiles un
peu d'essence de lavande et la soude
nécessaire à la réaction chimique la
savonnière se transforme en chef
pâtissier et procède au mélange comme
pour un gâteau elle va réaliser un
marbrage le bleu c'est de
l'indigo donc une
plante et l'argile
rose qui mélange d'argile blanche et
d'argile
rouge après avoir versé le savon dans un
moule Stéphanie laisse parler sa
créativité en décorant leur surface avec
des minéraux le savon va ensuite reposer
6 semaines avant d'être vendu environ 5
€ les 100 g c'est tout ce que j'aime il
y a la la partie création euh il y a la
partie savon à froid qui pour moi était
super important parce que c'est des
savons qui contrairement au savons
industriels qui sont moins éthiques et
moins intéressants au niveau des
ingrédients des propriétés puis de ce
qu'ils apportent après par la suite en
terme de soins pour la peau sensible aux
problèmes allergènes l'aspect biologique
est très important pour Stéphanie si
elle n'a pas fait de formation pour
devenir artisan savonnier elle n'est pas
novis dans ce domaine c'était au début
une passion que j'avais de faire mes
cosmétiques moi-même pour ma famille et
mon usage personnel et puis
aussi j'ai toujours été attirée par le
monde des parfums et d'ailleurs ça a été
mon métier pendant à peu près une
dizaine d'années avant de de me lancer
dans cette savonnerie où je travaillais
dans un laborato ire de confection de
parfum en 3 ans ses ventes ont doublé
mais Stéphanie prend son temps dans
cette aventure qui demande beaucoup
d'investissement elle espère atteindre
les 50000 € de chiffre d'affaires d'ici
quelques
années et une dernière information avant
de se quitter la cité des métiers de
trappe organise un zoom sur les métiers
d'urbaniste aménagement si ces métiers
vous intéressent le rendez-vous est de
14h à 16h le mercredi 21 janvier le
lycée Vette le duuc l'ordour des
architectes î-de-fance et la société
française d'urbaniste seront présents
pour animer la Réunion c'est la fin de
notre émission je vous remercie de nous
avoir suivi je vous donne rendez-vous la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de filco je vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée